we have two two by two matrices here and
in other videos we talk about how a two
by two matrix can represent a
transformation of the coordinate plane
of the two-dimensional plane where this
of course is the x-axis and this of
course is the y-axis what we're going to
do in this video is visualize these
transformations and get a visual
understanding for why it's reasonable
for a to have an inverse or why matrix a
is invertible and why it's not
reasonable for b to have an inverse
matrix or why matrix b is not invertible
so just as a reminder transformation
these transformation matrices
essentially tell us what to do with our
unit vectors for example we have the 1 0
unit vector and the first column of each
of these matrices tell us what the one
zero unit vector the vector that goes
one unit in the x direction what it will
get transformed to under each of these
transformations and then of course you
have the unit of the unit vector in the
y direction the zero one unit vector and
the second columns here tell us how we
would transform that
so let's first think about matrix a
matrix a transforms the one zero vector
into the 2 1 vector so the 2 1 vector is
going to look something like that and it
transforms the 0 1 vector into the 2 3
vector so the 2 3 vector is going to
look something like this
so one way to think about it instead of
our grid looking like this grid that i
already had here which is just our
standard coordinate axes this is
defining a new grid that would look
like this
and i define this new grid by looking at
our multiples of what the 1 0 vector has
been transformed into and we also look
at multiples of what the 0 1 vector has
been transformed into so for example
if i were to take this point right here
before it is transformed it has one of
each of these vectors well under
transformation of under this first
transformation it would be one of each
of these vectors so it's going to be one
two one vector plus one two three vector
so
this point will be mapped to this point
and by that same logic this point right
over here which is one unit more in the
x direction well now it's going to have
one unit more in the direction that x
has been the the x unit vector has been
transformed into
this point right over here by the same
logic will be one unit more in the
direction that the y unit vector has
been transformed into so it'll be there
and at this point by the same logic will
be transformed into that point and so
this region that i'm showing you in
white will get transformed to this
region
now there's some obvious things going on
here we have a two-dimensional area that
has been transformed to another
two-dimensional area and in fact it
looks like it has been scaled up in
other videos we have talked about that
this scale factor is going to be the
absolute value of the determinant of a
and it's clear that frankly not only is
this non-zero but it's going to be
greater than one it looks like we're
scaling up our area but the very fact
the very fact that this does not equal
zero
tells us that we are scaling from a
two-dimensional area to another
two-dimensional area and so it's
completely reasonable to be able to go
back you will for sure be able to find a
transformation that takes you from this
region to that region so that makes us
feel good that a inverse a inverse is
reasonable
now as a point of contrast let's think
about matrix b right over here
matrix b transforms the 1 0 unit vector
into the 2 1 unit vector so it
transforms it into this unit vector
actually very similarly to how a did it
but then let's see what it does to the 0
1 vector it transforms this vector into
the 4 2 vector 4 2 is this
notice
the 4 2 vector is just 2 of the 2 1
vectors it's going in the same direction
it just has a different size or a
different length or a different
magnitude so in this situation is taking
things in two-dimensional space and it's
turning them into combinations of things
that sit on this same direction so
everything in two dimensions is going to
be mapped to something along this line
here so this region if i were to apply
transformation b it's going to be a
region of this line over here anything
if i were to map it using matrix b it's
going to get mapped onto this line so
you're going to something with area and
then you're mapping it to something that
has no area so the scaling factor here
must be zero
so we know since the absolute value of
the determinant of b
is zero we could also fairly say that
the determinant of b is equal to zero
and then how are you going to have an
inverse matrix how are you going to have
something that can scale from 0 area to
something that has area so we know that
b inverse
does
not
exist
there's nothing that can transform us
back
and so there's a couple of things here
this reinforces this idea that if your
determinant of a transformation matrix
is zero you're not going to have an
inverse it's not invertible the other
thing to recognize is seeing the
patterns in the matrix itself here we
saw that the second column is just a
multiple of the first column it's twice
the first column two times two is four
one times two is two you can also view
it the other way around the first row is
a multiple of the second row
and you can play around with the math if
you wanted to generalize it and see if
that's the case the determinant will
always be 0. and that's because if you
view them as transformations they're all
it's going to map to a line and you're
going to lose all your area if you view
it as a representation for at least the
left hand side of a system of equations
you can think about it as lines that
have the same slope but we talk about
that in other videos